it's time we set the record straight
on the perfect macro split to meet your
Wellness [Music] goal hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to aby's Kitchen in today's video we're
going to be looking at what the science says
about the best proportions of protein fat and
carbs that we should be aiming for in our diet a
huge thank you to my friends that unlocked Fitness
and Nutrition who helped with the research on
this Eric Williamson is an RD and PhD and this is
his unique specialty so if you're looking for any
kind of one-on-one support for evidence-based diet
Consulting for Fitness or weight loss they are
your people so I'm going to be leaving a link them
below also keep in mind that I am not suggesting
anybody meticulously count out calories or macros
in this case this is simply to help answer
questions that I get all the time about General
balanced dietary patterns let me pop in here super
quick folks cuz I'm so excited to be working with
element this is a product that I was using years
ago when I was on my breastfeeding sagga and it
really helped me recover and I also use it a lot
in the summer when I'm playing tennis in the Heat
and it's always in my bag when I travel not to
mention a lot of my colleagues who work in Sports
Nutrition swear by element specifically because
it's got a science backed electrolyte ratio of a,
mg sodium 200 Mig potassium and 60 Mig magnesium
and it's got no colors sugars or fillers I've also
found that having my electrolytes in the morning
has had a really big positive impact on my sleep
so even on days when I'm not sweating a lot I
will usually still have half a packet I love all
things spicy so the mango chili is always my fave
but they've got nine different flavors including
their new chocolate caramel which is so strangely
addictive right now element is offering my viewers
a free sample pack with any order so that's eight
single serving packets free with any element order
this is a great way to try eight other flavors or
share element with a salty friend so get yours at
drink element.com slabby sharp and this deal is
only available through my link so you have to go
to d r i n k l m nt.com slabby sharp and thank
you guys again to element for sponsoring don't
forget to go to my description and hit up the link
drink element.com slabby to get yours today okay
so remember when the it diet was If It Fits your
Macros and Bros online were trying to convince one
another that eating five Pop-Tarts for breakfast
when trying to lose weight was like a solid plan
well that was based on this assumption that body
comp comes down to a specific split of carbs
protein and fats aka the three macronutrients
our bodies depend on to thrive so I talked about
why 100 calories of Pop-Tarts might not be the
same as like 100 calories of rice in my video
right here but assuming we're choosing whole food
sources is there a perfect Universal macro split
that we should all be adhering to well let's
break it down by primary goals first up let's
talk General health goals and I'm going to try to
build a little Bento Box situation here based on
these General recommendations keeping in mind that
this should not be copied or followed this is not
precise this is not an exact science because Foods
don't just contain one macro so just let to keep
in mind I'm showcasing this top level here for for
comparison sake so major health authorities have
crafted a recommended macro split for the general
population called the amdrs so this split has some
flexibility because these things don't need to be
exact but it's Loosely 45 to 65% of calories from
carbohydrates 10 to 35% of calories from protein
and 20 to 30% of your calories from fat so these
ranges are based on what is associated with
reduced risk of chronic disease however when you
dive in our absolute minimum needs are actually
pretty low for carbohydrates and fat and one could
argue that we don't actually have minimal needs
for carbohydrates considering that our bodies can
enter a state of ketosis to help Keep Us Alive in
the absence of carbs now fat needs are actually
quite low as well excluding the minimal needs for
essential fatty acids like Omega 6s and Omega-3s
that said going below the amdrs can increase the
risk of hormonal dysfunction so consuming below
20% of energy from from fat can increase the
risk of reduced testosterone in men and reduced
estrogen in women and going below 35% of energy
needs from carbs has also been shown to increase
the risk of low testosterone in men and am Menara
in active women particularly when accompanied by
a low calorie diet now a large reason for this
macro spit recommendation is not just about the
fat protein and carbs themselves but about the
micronutrients that this dietary pattern tends
to encourage so for example although vitamin and
mineral defic deficiencies leading to disease are
rare carbohydrate restricted diets can result
in suboptimal levels of thamin fully vitamin C
magnesium and fiber and on the other hand a fat
restricted diet can result in suboptimal intakes
of vitamin E and Omega-3s so this is generally
why we recommend balance over restriction but
that leaves us with protein so aside from water
we have a greater need for protein than any other
macronutrient because a large proportion of our
body is made up of protein so the recommended
protein intake for government guidelines is8 G
per kilogram as the minimum to prevent disease
but we don't just want to survive we want to
thrive so the optimal intake for protein for
General Health is at least 1.2 gam per kilogram
per day or around 15% of your calories this is
particularly important for preventing muscle loss
as we age and it's basically what most people on
non-restrictive diets are kind of getting anyway
so to quickly complet recap this section if the
goal is to maintain good health a very diet
consisting mostly of Whole Foods 45 to 65%
from carbohydrate 20 to 35% from fat and a protein
intake of at least 1.2 G per kilogram or around 15
to 35% will be ideal for most adults next let's
talk about the ideal macro ranges for weight loss
so although the keto and frugivores could argue
all day about whether we should be limiting carbs
or fat respectively the reality is it actually
doesn't matter that much when it comes to fat
loss rate in fact the differences have been
described as physiologically meaningless not
just that but according to the diet fits research
study there was no difference in Fat Loss rates
regardless of whether someone had the genetics to
supposedly present as more fat responsive or more
carb responsive or how insulin sensitive somebody
actually was some people will just find lowfat
easier and some people will find low carb easier
long-term tolerance and adherence is really what
matters most when it comes to weight loss success
so we now know that specific amounts of carbs and
fat are less important when it comes to weight
loss let's talk about what is important as a
macro protein protein is the one macronutrient
that can make a difference in Fat Loss rates
so higher protein intakes have been shown to
result in more weight loss and less lean mass
loss resulting in as much as a three time greater
effect on fat loss when going from a diet that is
about 10 to 15% protein to one that is 20 to
30% protein and there's a few main reasons why
this is number one protein is King in the satiety
hierarchy in my Hunger crushing combo so it helps
with appetite control and diet adherence better
than any other food component so for example one
study found that people spontaneously ate over
400 calories less when they increase calories
from protein from 15 to 30% number two protein
uses more energy for processes such as protein
synthesis which burns calories and can therefore
contribute to the calorie deficit and number three
you need more protein to stimulate protein
synthesis when you're in a calorie deficit
on a diet so a higher protein intake helps to
spare muscle mass from being broken down as fuel
so yeah protein is King for weight loss but how
much is enough hey I got you guys protein shakes
awesome I love protein protein protein protein
protein well ultimately this is really going to
depend on the size of the calorie deficit a
greater percentage of energy deficiency for
weight loss the more protein is recommended if we
consider that most people should be aiming for5
to 1% weight loss per week which is a rate that
also allows for optimal retention of muscle mass
that would coincide with about a 20% deficit and
at least 1.8 G per kilogram of protein okay so in
summary the percentage from carbs and fat matter
a lot less than protein when it comes to weight
loss but while we are in a calorie deficit
we want to push our protein intake towards
around the 30% range and at least 1.8 Gams per
kilogram while maintaining the general amdrs for
carbs and fat also please remember that weight
loss is both difficult and can pose a risk for
your relationship with food so always work with a
dietitian like one from unlocked if this is your
goal to help both reduce this risk and increase
your chances of keeping it off so as we've now
seen there's a baseline for protein that unless
you're on an extreme friger diet or just not
eating enough calories period you are almost
surely meeting needs will increase when in a
calorie deficit and they can potentially increase
on a per kilogram a body weight basis even further
when the goal is muscle gain as this systematic
review found optimal muscle mass gains come at 1.6
to 2.2 G per kilogram per day of protein intake
so that is around 75 to 1 gam per pound of body
weight but because only so much protein can be
used for muscle protein synthesis in one sitting
research like this review paper from our friend
Eric at unlock nutrition shows that it's important
to spread your intake out with at least. 3 G per
kilogram per meal in four to five meals or snacks
per day so usually this is around the 20 to 35 G
per meal Mark again the other macronutrients are
arguably less important for muscle gain but there
is evidence that sticking to a very low carb diet
can potentially result in lower performance of
strength training workouts which would impact your
rate of muscle and strength gain over time giving
a slight Edge over fat when it comes to importance
to summarize if muscle gain is the goal you're
not going to be in that same calorie deficit
that you might be for weight loss you might even
be in a caloric Surplus so even though the total
grams per kilogram of protein could potentially be
around the same or even higher around 1.6 to 2.2
G per kilogram the percentage of calories from
protein is lower than that is seen with weight
loss when we have to be more mindful of muscle
sparing so generally this looks like about 20% of
calories from protein per day spread out between
several meals and again staying within the amdr
ranges for carbs and fat and finally let's talk
about endurance exercise goals so things like
moderate to vigorous longer sessions of things
like running biking swimming Etc here the tables
turn and carbohydrates start to really really
matter as you can see in this chart right here
the higher the intensity and longer the workout
the more carbohydrate is needed to help fuel the
activity and refill those glycogen stores we also
need to consider protein this one actually might
surprise you but folks who are endurance training
for at least 1 to 2 hours of at least moderate
intensity training actually need about 1.8 g
of protein per kilogram which is on par with
the recommendations for weight loss and muscle
gain and this is because protein is used as a
fuel source during endurance training and what
you burn off needs to be replaced afterwards
also don't forget that protein is important for a
lot more than just muscle size there are so many
different adaptations to endurance exercise that
involves our proteins in our body so things like
the mitochondria blood vessels the heart Etc this
was actually part of Eric from unlocks PhD thesis
who suggested that if you're exercising for over
an hour of at least moderate intensity you should
be aiming for about 1.8 g of protein per kilogram
or 15% of energy needs from protein whichever one
is the higher value interestingly endurance
is really like the only scenario where macros
differ between the Sexes so women use more fat
as fuel and less carbohydrates but honestly the
difference ends up being like less than 10 gram
of carbohydrates used per hour for women by men so
that's like three spoonfuls of rice and definitely
not something that we need to stress over too much
also interesting interestingly women have lower
protein needs in the follicular phase of their
menstrual cycle but their needs during the ludal
phases are the same as men so generally speaking
we keep protein recommendations steady across
the cycle to prevent deficiency so to summarize
protein and carbs are particularly important for
endurance exercise your calorie needs will be high
when doing intense endurance exercises so even
though protein needs are again quite high around
1.8 G per kilogram this amounts to the General
Health average of around 50% of your calories
from protein a higher proportion of calories
should be coming from carbohydrates depending
on the intensity of your exercise so around the
60 to 65 Mark and then you're filling the rest
of the gaps with your fat so there you have it
depending on your goals your caloric needs and
macro splits will be very different and within
those goals needs are highly individualized so
if you do have specific goals I highly recommend
working with a dietitian like my colleagues at
unlock I'm going to be leaving a link to their
content below and on that note that's all that I
have for you guys today if you like this video
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below if you got any other questions
and I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music] bye